Professor John Merriman:
I don't know if you've been
following the events in France
in the last couple of days.
By the way, you could,
those of you who know French,
you can get TFN and France 2--I
prefer the latter--on your
computers, if you want to follow
it.
Just go to google.affaires,
or just go to Google and type
in France 2, or type in TFN,
and you can get the news from
one o'clock, that is treize
heures, or from vingt
heures,
from eight o'clock at night.
And my other two universities,
Rouen and Lyon II are
completely shut down,
and Rennes,
and Tours, and Toulouse,
because this is a law that
was--it's going to come into
effect called the Loi
Pécresse,
after the person who proposed
it.
And what it's going to do is
it's going to,
among other things,
it's going to make the budgets
of each university kind of
independent,
and it's an attempt to--this is
a logical transition into our
topic today--to Americanize
French universities so that in a
way the result,
which the students don't like,
is you'll have--you already
have sort of a gap between the
really good universities like
Paris I or Lyon II,
and the ones that just sort of
struggle along,
many of the new ones,
like the Pas-de-Calais,
that a friend of mine actually
set up when he was in the
ministry, and the little ones
like Chambéry and
Besançon and all the
others.
And because of the conditions
that are so difficult in French
universities,
which are woefully
understaffed,
and the ones that were built in
the early '60s and early '70s,
like the infamous Villetaneuse,
which is where I've given a
talk once, which was Paris--I
think it's Paris XIV,
and the conditions are just
very, very dreadful.
So, there's been a lot of
opposition there.
And now that Sarkozy is
President, that the
police--these interventions
musclées,
or kind of really brutal
interventions by the CRS
yesterday, and a couple of
people hurt at Nanterre,
where 1968 began,
and in Rennes I think--no in
Tours, rather.
So, as a matter of fact when I
was teaching in Rouen--I do a
course, I've done it the last
couple of Mays,
a course that's a couple of
weeks there, and the first day I
was doing it-- I'd just only met
my students and we went to a
demonstration against Sarkozy,
in front of the Palace of
Justice, and we were outnumbered
by the CRS.
And they took photos of all us.
And I think that one of the
things that's going to happen in
the future is that this is going
to be a very tense time,
I think.
Now, the big strikes in Paris
now, of course which,
comme d'habitude,
like all the time,
have taken out the trains
about, oh, one out of--about
fifteen percent of the trains
are running and the whole line,
if you know Paris,
the whole metro,
the RER, the whole line B,
line B, which goes from
Saint-Rêmy-les-Chevreuse
all the way to Roissy,
to the airport,
is completely shut down,
and the buses are running at
about ten percent.
And, so, it's just chaos.
I remember when everybody was
on strike when I was teaching at
Lyon.
I'd take--the trains weren't on
strike but the buses were and
I'd take the train up to Lyon,
from where we live or from near
where we live,
and I'd have to walk to Bron,
which is where Lyon II is,
and that's about five miles or
six miles, and I mean it's not a
long run or a long walk.
But people are very
inconvenienced.
And the other thing that's
going on, and the reason that
the railroads are out,
has nothing to do with the
Pécresse Law,
it has to do with the fact that
Sarkozy's attempt to Americanize
France involves sort of
withdrawing rights that certain
categories of workers received.
And there's a lot of anger now
in Paris, well in other cities
too, against the strikes.
And most people in France do
not approve of the strikes;
sometimes they do,
sometimes they don't.
I'll give you an example,
people that work on the metro,
who are underground,
the drivers of the metro,
they're underground all the
time.
Imagine working eight hours a
day and you're underground the
whole time--they have the right,
in principle--is it fifty,
does anyone remember if it's
fifty--do you remember if it's
fifty or fifty-five for les
chauffeurs de métro?
Fifty-five.
But there's some of the TGV
drivers--and that's a big,
high stress occupation;
it's not like driving a plane
but--you don't drive a plane,
I don't know,
you pilot a plane--but they
have the right to retire at
fifty.
Now, that seems awfully young,
and Sarkozy in his campaign
against the ill-fated campaign
of Ségolène Royal,
said that he "wanted to make
the French work again."
He also said a lot of other
provocative things,
and for a son of immigrants,
a fils des
immigrés,
who seems to hate immigrants,
very provocative things.
But, anyway,
he's going to carry these
policies until the very end,
and so this is going to happen
quite a lot.
I've got a sountenance de
thèse,
a thesis defense at Lyon,
a jury I have to participate
in,
in December,
and I'm kind of wondering
whether this is going to take
place.
But you can follow this through
the newspapers and through--the
other thing,
if you read French and
want--well, you can follow it
through the New York
Times online or anything,
but you can also get
libération.affaires,
so you can read Libé
every day or you can read
Le Monde or whatever,
if you want to keep up on this.
I'm going to be,
this afternoon,
calling my student pals in
Rouen and finding out what's
going on with them.
One of them,
who's always in every
demonstration,
he's always there,
and so last time he went out to
a demonstration and all these
police--and they know him
because he's in all the
demonstrations,
and this one policeman said to
him, he's got this huge stick
and he says to the student,
this little teeny guy,
and he has this stick and he
says, "I'm reserving this for
you Sven,"
and all of this.
And they have a memory too.
But, anyway,
so ça bouge en France
maintenant.
Well, I want to talk--that is,
I think, a logical thing to
talk about, because I'm going to
talk about anti-Americanism in
France.
And it's hard to do,
to talk about anti-Americanism
from 1945 until now in a mere
fifty minutes.
And let me say at the outset
that having spent half my life
or half the last thirty years of
my life in France--more than
that,
actually--I've never once
encountered anti-Americanism,
which ça n'a rien
à voir avec,
it doesn't matter.
But what I am saying is that
the anti-Americanism in France
has always been against the
United States policies and,
particularly in the earlier
days, the United States' sort of
cultural imperialism,
but has had nothing to do with
anti-Americanism against
American people.
I've been introduced in a book,
in which I contributed some
sort of random musings about
living in Ardèche,
as a political refugee in
France, at various times,
and people joke about that.
So, I'm differentiating
anti-Americanism,
like people they don't like
Americans, with anti-U.S.
policies and an anti-,
what was considered by many
people, particularly
intellectuals,
sort of a cultural arrogance,
that risked making France less
than what it had always been.
And, so, let me talk a little
bit about that.
And here I'm drawing heavily at
the first part of the lecture on
my friend Dick Kuisel's book on
anti-Americanism in the early
stages;
but it's an interesting story
and it's one that's worth
telling.
Now, when I teach in Rouen I go
often to this café
that's near the railroad
station there,
and it's a café
where Sartre and Simone de
Beauvoir, who are well-known to
almost everybody,
used to go all the time,
and it's kind of fun to be in a
café where you imagine
that they were.
And they were a good example of
kind of the intellectual
anti-Americanism that emerged
after World War Two.
Now, why did this kind of
philosophical and intellectual
anti-Americanism emerge?
You have to put it in the
context of the ideological
controversies that emerged out
of World War One;
and by that I mean from 1945
well into the mid-1950s.
There were dock strikes against
the arrival of U.S.
military equipment.
Remember, the Americans had
huge, huge bases in France until
the time of de Gaulle.
If you go to the town of
Châteauroux--which isn't a
very interesting town and the
only great restaurant in it left
and moved to Tours--you'd go by
these just abandoned airfields
that used to just be full of
American military,
air force equipment,
and officers.
And, so, you see a lot of these
signs.
There were angry outbursts even
against the Marshall Plan.
The Marshall Plan,
as you know from other courses,
brought American aid in great
quantities to Western Europe,
and one of the reasons was to
keep Western Europe out of
Soviet influence.
And this drew predictable
attacks from the Parti
Communiste, from the Communist
Party,
because of the obvious
ideological division that was
the Cold War.
So, and it also was the time
when the Rosenbergs,
in this country,
were executed for allegedly
passing nuclear secrets to
Soviet agents;
and these kinds of executions,
as had been the execution of
Sacco and Vanzetti,
who were anarchists who were
executed in 1927,
these have, with the mass
press,
although way before Internet,
great ramifications.
But the French economy grows so
rapidly over the next thirty
years, thirty glorious years,
and part of the rise of
consumerism and the consumer
culture--in France it was backed
by the arrival of such novelties
as refrigerators and things like
that--was very much identified
with U.S.
culture and was debated,
particularly by intellectuals,
rather heatedly.
There were pro-American
intellectuals who made the case
in the very beginning that the
American path was the way to go.
The most famous was probably
Raymond Aron,
a-r-o-n, but there were others
like François
Mauriac--and I can't remember if
Chip in his book mentions--yes,
I'm sure he does.
But the Communist intellectuals
were adamantly against all
things that were American,
and of course they were very
much over the top.
Dick Kuisel quotes the famous
Communist poet,
Louis Aragon,
describing the U.S.
as, quote, "a civilization of
bathtubs and
frigidaires," in 1951,
as if this was a very bad
thing;
and he did not mean it,
as Kuisel says,
as a compliment.
It was the Parti Communiste,
the Communist Party,
that coined phrases like the
"Coca-Colanization of
France."
And the arrival of Coca Cola in
France of course was a terribly
important moment--more about
that in a minute.
At the time of the NATO pact,
the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization,
in 1949,
these kinds of debates hit a
boiling point,
and in an age of graffiti,
the graffiti,
"Yankee Go Home," was a bit
everywhere.
Now, the U.S.
nuclear capacity,
which was of course very soon
matched by the Soviet nuclear
capacity, seemed to raise the
cry against the Americans.
There was a SACM conference in
1950 against nuclear power.
And France is a country that
almost leads the world in the
percentage of its energy that is
drawn from these nuclear plants,
of which several are not all
that far from us,
and there's a big sort of
anti-nuclear reaction now that's
mostly through ecologists and
the Greens and folks like that.
But in the beginning,
because the Americans are the
ones who had used the nuclear
bomb--other people have never
used a nuclear bomb,
never sensed it,
have used the nuclear bomb.
We live in a world in which
Israel has a nuclear bomb,
in which Pakistan has a nuclear
bomb,
in which India has a nuclear
bomb, as well as France and
Britain, and China as well,
I do believe.
So, therefore all of this is
still very scary.
But in the origins this
anti-Americanism was increased
by the fear that the Americans
and their Cold War against the
Soviet Union would turn--that
the damage would not be done in
Mississippi or in Minnesota but
would be done in Europe.
And, so, intellectuals also
accused the Americans of
ignoring European culture.
Remember the infamous Donald
Rumsfeld referred scathingly to
"old Europe," at a time when the
Americans were invading Iraq,
as if old Europe with its
quaint streets,
and old churches,
and long cultures were
something not worth remembering.
But, again, the critics of
American culture were over the
top.
L'Humanité,
the Communist newspaper,
and still today,
said that one could starve even
if one owned a telephone;
and the telephone,
where you can't even find a
fixed phone anymore--I can't
telephone,
I can't even call on a phone
when I go back to University of
Michigan because there is
literally only one fixed phone
left on the campus,
and I don't have a cell phone
because I don't like cell
phones, I can't stand them.
I agree with those people who
said that they had great faith
in humanity until the cell
phone;
and plus my daughter's lost
three of them already.
But the French Minister of
Communications,
in 1964--this is the French
Minister of Communications,
in 1964, avant vous,
before you existed,
but not before I existed--he
called the telephone a gimmick,
in 1964.
But it wasn't the telephone
that drew heat it was above
all--well the refrigerators,
you couldn't tell the average
housewife living wherever,
in the Morbihan or someplace,
in Brittany or wherever,
that the refrigerator wasn't a
good deal.
But, yet, for the Communist
Party a frigo,
a refrigerator,
a Frigidaire which is a
model--I don't know if it still
is--was only good for making
ice-cubes for fancy aperitifs
where you would drink American
or Scottish--American bourbon or
Scotch whiskey.
So, they--Aragon,
this again is the Communist
poet--wrote, "a Ford automobile,
the civilization of Detroit,
the assembly line,
the atomic danger,
encircled by napalm"--now,
he said this early on.
Remember, it's the Americans
who used napalm in Vietnam,
it was the Americans used
napalm in Vietnam.
"Here is the symbol of the
subjugation to the dollar,
applauded even in the land of
Molière,
the Yankee more arrogant than
the Nazi holocaust"--this is
absurd--"substitutes the machine
for the poet,
Coca Cola for poetry,
the Ford for Victor Hugo."
It degenerated to that extent.
A great sociologist called
Edgar Morin, who has a brilliant
book on a--it's called The
Red and the White,
about a Breton village--he
called Readers Digest "a
pocketsize stupifier,
a drug for little minds," and
he attacked, was one of the
earliest to attack
Franglais--and more about that
in awhile--that is,
the absorption of American
terms into the French language;
toothpaste, for example,
instead of dentifrice,
flooding the French language.
But, again, you have to put
this in the context of the
times, and that's what I guess
what historians try to do.
Sixty percent of the people in
the Communist Party thought the
U.S.
was readying an aggressive war,
and almost ninety-five percent
of people in the Communist Party
were against the presence of
U.S.
bases in France.
Now, remember,
the guy who got rid of the U.S.
bases in France was Charles de
Gaulle, who was anything but a
communist, who was completely
opposite of a communist,
but his view,
as we'll see,
was that France had to maintain
its status as a great power,
had to have a neutral path and
influence in places where French
was spoken,
particularly in West and North
Africa, and in the Middle East
in parts, in Lebanon,
and things like that.
So, there were some
intellectuals who tried to find
a third way, who weren't kind of
parroting the Communist Party,
or were going to kowtow the way
Sarkozy is to America.
And Le Monde,
for example,
which is without question the
most reputable newspaper in
France,
though Libé is
quite good too,
et c'est plutôt
à mon goût,
but it took a more neutral
position in all of this,
because there were many people
in France who weren't Communists
that thought that the Marshall
Plan was a way of buying off
Europe.
And I wasn't--I was vaguely
around in those days,
but the fear was,
after World War One there was
the thought that nobody would
ever want another war;
after World War Two,
and after the atomic bomb,
and after the horrors of all
that had happened,
and the Holocaust,
people were quite certain that
there would be another war.
So, it was a time of great
fear, and so these were big
issues.
In 1952, at the time of the
visit of U.S.
General Matthew Ridgeway to
take control of NATO forces,
there were huge demonstrations
against the United States.
He was called a butcher in the
Korean War, which certainly
wasn't true;
he was called a war criminal
and that wasn't true either.
But this came at a time when it
was the government of a guy,
who just died only a couple of
years ago,
lived to be about
130-years-old,
called Antoine Pinay,
who was from Saint-Chamond,
near Saint-Étienne,
if I remember correctly,
and he had been accused of
collaboration during the war,
and he was in power.
And he tried to ludicrously
enough break the influence of
the Parti Communiste.
And one of their leaders--I
didn't know about this incident
till I read Kuisel--one of the
incidents was he accused Jacques
Duclos,
a name you can forget,
but he was an interesting guy
who was leader of the Communist
Party,
of being a spy for the Soviets,
and his proof was that they'd
found two dead pigeons in the
backseat of his car,
and an autopsy on the birds,
that he thought they were
carrier pigeons that were
smuggling,
going to send secrets off to
some Soviet spies,
somewhere out of the country.
And of course they did an
autopsy on these birds and they
discovered--I don't know how you
do this, do an autopsy;
I didn't want to be in the
room--but they were not carrier
pigeons but they were
pigeons--people in France eat
pigeons,
pigeonneau,
and that they simply--he had
them in his backseat because he
was going to take home and cook
them,
hopefully with lots of garlic,
and to eat them.
And Jean-Paul Sartre,
he said it at the same time,
that if he had to choose sides
in the Cold War,
he would choose the USSR.
Now Sartre, like lots of fellow
travelers, were delusional about
what had happened in Stalin's
Soviet Union,
and his partner,
Simone de Beauvoir,
who's terribly important in the
rise of feminism,
as I'm sure you know,
she came to the U.S.
in 1947--she had been in
1947--and she liked the sort of
dynamism of the American
economy,
and she liked its freedom,
but she was immediately
suspicious of racism in the
United States,
in the 1940s and the 1950s,
as indeed in our own time,
sadly, though not as much,
was a time of racism;
and she said so,
she came right out and said,
and that became a part of the
anti-American discourse.
Because when the Americans
would get holier than thou about
how people in Europe treated
their minorities,
all you had to look to the
United States,
where I can think back to my
own childhood when the three
freedom workers were so brutally
murdered in Mississippi;
and they would point to that.
Now, what about the role of
Coca-Cola in all of this?
I imagine you may have seen
Coca-Cola a few times in your
lives.
It became--it still is so
identified with America,
and it probably is,
I think it's fair to say,
the single item that is most
identified in the rest of the
world with the United States;
that you couldn't talk to
people in France or anywhere
else about baseball and you
could not talk to them about
hotdogs,
although this strange thing
emerged in the 1960s called
le hotdog,
which are two sort of
miserably,
almost frozen frankfurters with
some sort of god-awful cheese
put on them, and put in what was
then the equivalent of a
microwave;
but it was Coca Cola.
And as you know the product was
created I think in the late
1880s.
It's very hard to get into the
archive, though Kuisel managed
to do it, to get into the
Coca-Cola archives;
afraid you might find that
recipe.
And of course I think somebody
told me that cocaine was put
originally into Coke,
at the beginning of it all.
Let me give you some examples
how Coke and American view of
itself and view of the world
came to be.
"We will see that every man in
uniform gets a bottle of
Coca-Cola for five cents
wherever he is and whatever it
costs,"
was what Coca-Cola had to say
about the relationship between
soldiers if they survived the
Bataan death march and whatever,
and that was it.
Coca-Cola actually sent people
as "technical observers," a
phrase they used,
to see where bottling plants
could, after the fighting ended,
be set up in Europe.
One U.S.
soldier wrote a letter in which
he said, "to my mind I am in
this damn mess as much to help
to keep the custom of drinking
Cokes as I am to preserve the
million other benefits our
country blesses its citizens
with."
Sixty-four bottling plants were
set up in Europe after the war,
immediately after the war,
within a couple of years.
They expand to Belgium and
Luxembourg and the Netherlands
in 1947, also to Switzerland and
Italy, and then to France in
1949.
The Olympics of 1950 were held
in Finland, in Helsinki,
and there was not yet--had not
yet been time to build a
Coca-Cola plant.
So, what they did is they got a
hold of some D-Day landing
vessels, filled them with
Coca-Cola,
and the Coca-Cola Company
landed on the shores of Finland,
literally, with all these
publicity material and with
720,000 bottles of Coca Cola.
Now, the chairman of--I didn't
know this either until I read
Kuisel--the chairman of
Coca-Cola was James Farley,
who was a former aide to
Franklin Roosevelt and thus he
was very--had good contacts,
and he was a militant
anti-Communist who identified
the drinking of Coca-Cola with
democracy.
The Soviets and in their
satellite states did not drink
Coca-Cola but good old Americans
drank Coca-Cola.
Now, you're going to run into
huge lobbies in these countries.
In Belgium you're going to run
into the beer lobby,
terribly important.
In the Pays-Bas,
in the Netherlands,
you're going to run into the
beer lobby,
and in France you will run head
on into that lobby you already
know something about,
the wine lobby,
which in a way is neither Left
nor Right, but--it's neither
Left nor Right,
it's a little more complicated
than that.
And they tried to stir up
popular action against
Coca-Cola.
A Communist paper in Italy said
that drinking Coke would make
children's hair turn white and
therefore you shouldn't do that.
In Austria The
Communist,
the biggest communist newspaper
in Vienna, wrote that Coca-Cola
plants,
by virtue of the machines they
used, could be easily
transformed into plants capable
of turning out nuclear bombs,
and so that good Viennese and
good Austrians should avoid the
"insidious, numbing drink."
Cokes had begun to arrive in
France after World War One but
only in very small numbers and
in extremely fancy cafés.
And, so, the Coca-Cola--Kuisel
got into the archives to find
all this--Coca-Cola marketers
divided France into six regions
and figured they should
anticipate each person drinking
six Coca-Colas per year.
The problem is that foreign
investments, such as building
plants, required the permission
of the Ministry of Finance;
and that all this anxiety comes
along.
The Ministry of Finance gets
involved in all of this
business, the debate reaches the
Chamber of Deputies in the
1950s;
and also this merges with other
fears of other American
products.
John Deere--some of you may be
from Illinois,
isn't that where John Deere is
made,
the tractors and all that--and
that is by far the biggest
successful company in marketing
machinery that's been part of
the French agricultural
revolution since World War Two;
but of course the little
producers in France were against
John Deere as well.
It also comes at a time,
as you know,
of widespread outrage of
intellectuals and filmmakers
against the Hollywoodization of
French movie theaters,
and because France,
its idea and attitudes towards
their own movies has always been
that as its attitudes towards
almost all industrial
production,
that France makes these fine
little products of quality,
and the arrival of,
God-forbid, the Charlton
Heston's of the world and John
Wayne and all this stuff--so,
these debates are going on
among intellectuals and film
watchers, et cetera.
These debates just go on and on.
Radio stations in France now
have to play a certain
percentage of French music,
as opposed to Bruce
Springsteen, and the Stones,
and whatever;
they have to have a certain
percentage.
And, so, there is still this
paranoia that English or French
music or other kinds of music
coming will wipe out what's left
of the French music industry,
and that people won't play
Jacques Brel anymore,
or Georges Brassens,
or Léo Ferré,
or Johnny Hallyday,
who anyway who was born Belgian
and he has his own problems,
so it has nothing to do with it.
But, yet, when there are these
debates it seemed like the ties
between Coke and the U.S.
Government were even stronger.
Coca-Cola demanded that the
U.S.
State Department intervene in
some way to stop this kind of
uprising against the arrival of
Coca-Cola.
U.S. papers went wild.
"Coca-Cola was not injurious to
the health of American soldiers
that liberated France from the
Nazis,
so that Communist deputies
could sit in session today," was
one editorial in a U.S.
paper.
You can't spread the doctrines
of Marx among people who drink
Coca-Cola.
The dark principles of
revolution and a rising
proletariat may be expounded
over a bottle of vodka on a
scarred table,
such as in Morry's or some
place like that,
or even a bottle of brandy,
but it's utterly fantastic to
imagine two men stepping to a
soda fountain and ordering a
couple of Cokes in which to
toast the downfall of their
capitalist oppressors.
And so it went.
But Coca-Cola arrived in
France, it got permission to be
produced in France and to be
drunk in France,
and still is,
though often by American
tourists in France.
I have been on several
occasions in really good,
and in one case even great--and
this is not dissing Americans,
forgive me--great restaurants
and seeing Americans ordering
Coca-Cola with their four or
five-course meal.
And that does make me sad.
Does it make me sound like a
snob?
I've seen people drink milk,
too, and things like that.
Anyway, what can I say?
I shouldn't get so involved in
all this stuff.
How did people like Coca-Cola?
A poll, a sondage--the
French take to American polls,
do these polls all the time;
sondage is the word for
a poll--in 1953 said that only
seventeen percent of people who
drank it liked it,
and sixty percent not at all,
and the other ones couldn't
remember because they'd gone on
to something else,
drinking something else I guess.
But the dykes began to break
and millions of Cokes are sold
every year in France,
as everywhere.
Now, this is just an aside but
this is the same case as in
Africa;
the debates have not been the
same but one of the interesting
things, and I think sad things
about the places I know in
Africa--which are very few,
but I have family members who
know Africa pretty well--is that
the domination of Coke,
particularly in places that are
Muslim, in which people don't
drink alcoholic beverages,
the domination of Coke,
and Fanta, which are very,
very expensive,
for people who have almost no
money,
and the Fanta sort of becomes
the equivalent of a celebration
with champagne in France,
or the United States,
or some places where people
drink.
And, so, some of the same
issues, some of the same debates
are there, and these companies
just make zillions off these
drinks.
And I'm not criticizing these
companies, am I?
I guess I don't know.
But, anyway,
now let's talk about some of
the other aspects of
anti-Americanism before I end in
fifteen minutes or so with the
obvious ones,
today.
Well, architecture, for example.
Many of the debates about
preservation,
about keeping Paris,
Poitiers, anywhere you want to
name,
the beautiful center of
Strasbourg, the way they have
always been, have involved
fighting against the
skyscraperization,
if you will,
the gratte-ciels,
les gratte-ciels,
the skyscrapers in France.
In the late 1960s there was a
huge debate over the Tour
Montparnasse.
And the Tour Montparnasse is
right on the--it's where the
Station of Montparnasse is in
Paris, it's right beyond the
Boulevard Montparnasse there;
was built with the enthusiastic
cooperation, if not money in the
pockets, of George Pompidou,
the President of France,
who said, "we must renounce
this outmoded aesthetic"--that's
an exact quote.
And, so, the big battle over
the Tour Montparnasse which
is--here I give my own view but,
mon vue--it is a hideous
building that is a blight on the
skyline of Paris.
And it's said the only thing
good about it is you can't see
it when you're viewing Paris
from the top;
and they have the elevator that
shoots up to the top;
and it destroyed--well,
anyway, what can one say,
it's an obvious thing.
Now, people that defended the
Tour Montparnasse,
which is identified with
Chicago and the skyscrapers,
would say, "well,
look, well people criticized
the Tour d'Eiffel,
the Eiffel Tower when it was
built in 1888 and 1889";
and Zola was among those who
signed saying this is awful,
it must go.
And it is part of what people
go to see.
Now, people do not go to see
the Tour Montparnasse because
the Eiffel Tower represented
changes in industry and steel
and iron and all this stuff,
and the Tour Montparnasse just
represents kind of an American
approach to architecture that
the traditionalists found
wanting.
And, so, what they did
subsequently is they built La
Défense,
which is outside of Paris but
you can see it if you stand,
for example,
in the Tuileries,
or around there;
you can see it beyond the Arc
d'Triomphe--and that's where
lots of business is,
that's the kind of
Americanization of French
architecture and business.
But generally the French have
been very good of trying to
protect Paris from the planners
who would destroy the way the
place looks with an Americanized
kind of architecture.
There've been other problems
too.
The constructions at Place
d'Italie and the Tour
Montparnasse became only the
most famous.
And appropriately enough,
these kinds of battles to
protect Paris against this kind
of architecture have involved
the far Right,
conservative Right;
not the faisceaux,
the fascist Right,
but the far Right,
like my late friend Louis
Chevalier,
a very conservative man,
who was the greatest historian
in Paris, or my friend
François Laurier who's
now head of the committee to
preserve old Paris--with people
on the Left,
like sort of the French
equivalent to me,
against the Center,
against the kind of
planners who just want to
make money.
But other aspects of
Americanization--the word
pavilion in France--people
wanted to have their houses in
the prosperous suburbs at best,
at Saint-Remy-les-Chevreuse,
for example,
most--or the suburbs,
in the time we're talking
about,
until 1945, are miserable
places, but that people in
Saint-Germain en Laye in the
west of Paris or Versailles,
you know what,
they wanted to have their
pavilion which was a big kind of
modern Americanized house with
all these things--cell phones,
refrigerators,
all this business,
swimming pools and lawns.
What could be more American
than lawns?
Now, the vast majority of the
people who live in the Parisian
region do not live in houses,
they live in apartments,
and the vast majority live in
buildings that they do not
own--or,
not the vast majority but the
majority do.
But that became a big issue.
The television,
the television--people thought
that television would destroy
France.
I used to say that when Charles
de Gaulle died,
finally,
Colombey-les-Deux-Eglises,
he died of boredom watching
French TV;
because French TV,
which has some of the best
stuff around but also has some
of the worst,
just talk shows that go on,
and on, and on,
it's just numbing.
But also they took all these
things that I've never watched
in my life, like Dallas,
that used to be a big show and
all these things;
I have no idea what they are.
But people--even our very dear
friends, you go there and
they're watching this stuff.
Well, TV's not just American,
but that whole kind of culture
was identified with America,
and intellectuals didn't like
that very much;
people should be reading
books-- and they should be
reading books too,
but who am I to say?
I watch ESPN hours every day
and every game that's on,
so I can't really say I don't
watch TV.
Clothing, it used to be--the
first years and years that I was
living in France or went to
France,
you could tell who was an
American in about one second by
looking at their feet;
I don't spend a lot of time
looking at people's feet but you
could tell the way they looked
because they wore tennis shoes,
and tennis shoes now are called
baskets.
But now everybody wears them
the same way.
And jeans the same thing,
because there weren't jeans in
France;
now everybody wears jeans.
I can still tell who's American
and who isn't,
usually.
But the clothing that was
identified with America was seen
as being somehow un-French.
And of course there's the big
war between France high couture
of French fashion and trying to
preserve,
as Milan tries to also,
and they've been very
successful at that.
But clothing was one thing as
well.
Euro Disney,
what can one say about Euro
Disney?
Somebody called it a cultural
Chernobyl;
Chernobyl was the big nuclear
plant that blew up in Kiev--and
certainly the idea of Mickey
Mouse and Goofy and all these
people.
And you go and you-- I've never
been there, I would never walk
in the place;
you spend cinquante
balles, you've spent,
what, fifty euros to get in and
so your kids can get sick eating
American cotton candy.
But, again, people go over the
top.
Or McDonald's, ha ha.
McDonald's, which started in
France really in the '80s.
Burger King tried and failed.
Now, McDonald's is a big issue,
and José
Bové,
who came to Yale a couple of
years ago--José
Bové is a guy who
now--who became identified with
the struggle against McDonald's.
He actually lived two years in
L.A., though he speaks
English--I wasn't here when he
came,
my daughter was a translator
for him, and introduced him and
all that.
But he's the one who led the
struggle to try to first of all
to preserve his part of the
Aveyron,
Larzac, against making it a
strafing practice range for the
French Air Force,
and has gone after McDonald's,
as representing the
globalization that's going to
hurt local commerce.
Now, McDonald's has tried to
compromise in some ways,
and if you go get a
McDonald's--and I won't go in
the place;
well, I shouldn't say that
because we're recording this,
but I haven't been in years in
France--but they have these
little salads with a few pieces
of goat cheese in it,
to go along with the two
million calorie burger,
and all that.
But what José
Bové did is that he and
his friends went up and broke
up--didn't hurt anybody,
but they sort of trashed a
McDonald's in Millau,
which is Aveyron,
in the south,
right near this huge,
huge bridge,
the biggest span bridge in
Europe.
And of course he went on trial
and he became a presidential
candidate, and I guess--my
daughter said he was a great
guy.
But McDonald's became an issue.
And I said, "well,
maybe it won't work."
But McDonald's,
because you can eat cheaply
there, because everything's so
expensive in France,
so expensive,
they're always just--well you
could drive by,
there's one in Auvergnat,
there's one everywhere;
they're always full of people
eating whatever it is they eat
there.
So, it became a symbol more
important than the reality,
McDo--McDo, comme on dit en
français--became a
symbol of globalization,
first of Americanization and
then of globalization.
And then what comes along now
but Starbucks.
There's three or four.
There's one in the Marais in
Paris, there's one I saw
in--some are on Opéra,
and there are a couple of other
ones there, and they soon will
be everywhere.
And even
hyper-marchés,
supermarkets;
now, people don't just hate
supermarkets anymore,
but they used to.
The big ones are Leclerc,
and Auchan, and Mamouth and all
these--Leclerc is probably the
biggest, I mean the upscale
version, after Marché.
Now, I remember in the 1970s
that people thought that
supermarkets were just terrible
things.
Why?
Because they were going to,
and did, destroy local
commerce, that most villages now
do not have the little
épicerie,
that grocery store,
that made it possible for old
ladies just to walk the
equivalent of a few hundred
meters to buy their milk,
and now they can't do that
anymore.
Now, it's more than just the
disappearance of a way of buying
food, it's the disappearance of
a place where you get together
and exchange news in the
morning.
Our grocery store disappeared
about ten years ago,
or about eight years ago,
because everybody goes to the
super-marché;
hyper-marché,
super-marché,
c'est la même chose.
Though the other thing that it
could attack,
could interfere with,
but has not as much as we
feared,
were markets,
the Saturday market,
the Wednesday market;
the Saturday and Wednesday
market, depending on the size of
the town, that are all over
France.
And in fact people still,
even young people your age,
still have a sense that you've
got to protect--you've got to
save the market and you've got
to--the people that produce
there,
that bring what they produce in
their fields there,
buy goats cheese,
picodons,
whatever, wine from producers
directly.
And that's part of the
ambience, that's what's great
about living in France,
or living in Germany,
or living in Pays-Bas,
or living anywhere,
in Belgium.
And, so, many people will go
and buy the big things of milk
and the big items,
paper towels and all that,
but then they will still go to
the market, not just for a trip
of nostalgia but because the
products,
they know they're buying from
people they know and all that;
so that fear probably turned
out to be less than one had
worried about.
And then of course there's the
question of Franglais.
Every about,
oh, maybe five,
or six, or seven years,
somebody in one of the
ministries gets it into his or
her head that Franglais has to
disappear from the vocabulary,
the official vocabulary,
the administrative vocabulary
of France.
Franglais is the absorption
into daily parlance of words
that are non-French,
of which--the first one that
really took over,
at least in my memory,
was le weekend.
And there were attempts,
I think under Giscard
D'Estaing, and there's one even
more recently under early stages
of Jacques Chirac's presidency,
to send stern circulars around
saying in a correspondence you
shall not use le weekend,
but you'd rather use la fin
de la semaine,
the end of the week.
Well, that lasted a matter of
days because that's simply not
terribly practical.
English words began to
permeate, with a sort of chic
sense of being cool,
the French language--le
drugstore.
I can remember around Paris
Saint-Germain,
at the metro there,
en face,
right across there was le
drugstore;
and it was, it was a pharmacy
and it had your basic green
flashing light saying it's a
pharmacy, but they also sold all
sorts of things.
It was almost like anticipating
a supermarket,
and the term was le
drugstore.
It wasn't une pharmacie
or la pharmacie,
it was le drugstore.
And people debated that.
You could go on and on about
this.
I'll just give you a couple of
examples;
these are obvious ones,
I just wrote them down because
they're obvious.
Après les
sweaters;
a sweater d'hiver;
voici les fully
fashioned des beaux
jours;
new, c'est smart,
s-m-a-r-t--vo
ilà--votre
shopping club,
le veritable wash and wear,
les drinks de gens
raffinés,
the drink of people who are
refined.
Now, this had already started
to happen in the 1890s with
certain terms,
as I suggested when I was
talking about Émile
Henry,
that began to--the long drink,
for example--that began to
infiltrate the French language.
The hotdog became the chien
chaud, in these times of
these various commands.
But basically with
globalization and with the
American cultural dominance,
these attempts are basically
just putting small fingers in
very large dykes.
Why did it matter so much,
all of this?
It's because France is no
longer a great power,
and intellectuals and lots of
other people in France,
including me,
are determined that French
culture retain its place in the
world.
And I am chronically sad to see
another supermarket go up where
there already have been two of
them;
it saddens me terribly to see
the golden arches almost
everywhere now,
and Subway,
which is a chain I actually
happen to like a lot,
and those are becoming all over
the place.
So, we're fighting against the
ways that cannot be halted,
but in a way may not be all a
very bad thing,
so long as a sense of
perspective is maintained;
and that often was not
maintained in the early days of
the almost hysterical battle
against the mounting empire of
Coca-Cola.
Have a wonderful Thanksgiving
vacation, see you next time,
and Go Blue.